une simple rose un bouquet de fleurs à
la main le cœur lourd mais le pas décidé
les élèves du lycée Saint Thomas
retrouvent leur établissement au
lendemain du drame cet après-midi à la
demande du ministère de l'Éducation un
instant de recueillement a été organisé
dans les collèges et lycées qui
n'étaient pas en vacances je vous
demande s'il vous plaît de respecter une
minute de silence
et de penser à râler
ces premières déclarations semblent
confuses selon les premiers éléments il
était venu avec un couteau dans ses
affaires la thèse de l'acte prémédité
est donc privilégie ce garçon aurait
déclaré j'ai ruiné ma vie tout est fini
et il aurait fait état également de ce
que quelqu'un aurait pris possession de
son corps concernant cette fois le
profil psychologique du mise en cause il
a fait une tentative de suicide au mois
d'octobre dernier il était depuis suivi
par un psychologue et des
antidépresseurs lui étaient prescrit oui
la santé mentale d'une façon générale
est une préoccupation une préoccupation
pas d'aujourd'hui c'est une
préoccupation déjà depuis plusieurs mois
les suites de la crise sanitaire nous
l'avons vu ont eu un impact et en
particulier sur la santé mentale des
jeunes le prix de la consultation chez
le médecin pourrait bientôt augmenter la
sécurité sociale propose du nouveau une
augmentation de 5 euros pour passer de
25 à 30 euros mais cela a concernerait
uniquement les professionnels qui
accepteront des engagements
supplémentaires nous avons fait
plusieurs pas vers les médecins
maintenant voilà faut que chacun mange
vous parlais tout à l'heure de 1 euro 50
d'augmentation de la consultation
j'entends des mots comme indécent il
faut peut-être toutes les choses aussi à
leur place un euro 50 de plus pour la
consultation globalement pour un médecin
c'est 7000 euros de plus par an c'est un
beau 13ème mois et samedi cette station
d'autoroute totale va devoir revoir ses
prix le litre de diesel est d'essence
sera plafonné à 1,99 € pour toute
l'année 2023 côté grande surface pas de
geste prévu non plus sur les réseaux
sociaux le président de Système U
s’estime lésé
on aimerait beaucoup pouvoir annoncer en
cas de hausse un prix maximum garanti de
1,99 le litre sauf que la loi nous
interdit de vendre à perte c'est un vrai
coup de pouce ou c'est un coup de com
pour le moment ça mange pas de pain moi
je peux pas promettre ça parce que c'est
lui une autre fournisseur donc on verra
les conditions qu'il nous fera lui et
d'autres les raffineurs c'est un
dispositif de lisibilité de visibilité
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas l'effet
crainte que l'essence atteignent des
plafonds à de 30 de 40 le litre comme on
a pu le connaître j'ai les cours sur le
site du gouvernement pour le moment le
moins cher sur sur les carburants c'est
le clair puis systémique puis
Intermarché puis Carrefour Hyper puis
seulement total access donc même en
temps normal il peut faire encore un peu
d'effort mais là ce qu'il est allé aussi
loin que possible que ce soit encore une
fois aussi on verra dans les mois à
venir saluons déjà le fait qu'un geste
moi j'étais dans des médias ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines on me
disait il se passera rien on voit rien
venir on peut au moins reconnaître qu'il
y a un geste qui est fait la candidature
de M6 pour le renouvellement de sa
fréquence sur la TNT a été retenue hier
par l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
l'arcom le projet de Xavier Niel à lui
était écarté une information qui
pourrait faire grand bruit une alliance
longtemps juger impensable et pourtant
près de 60 ans après leur première
rencontre les Rolling Stones et les
Beatles pourraient se retrouver sur un
nouvel album Mick Jagger et Kiss Richard
d'un côté Paul McCartney et Rigo star de
l’autre serait en train en train de
préparer un disque commun les États-Unis
frappés par une vaste tempête hivernale
d'importantes chutes de neige et le
blizzard qui ont impacté une large
partie du pays du trafic routier très
perturbé notamment dans le Wyoming vous
voyez ces images très impressionnantes
de camions qui dérape d'est en ouest
c'est quasiment tout le pays qui fait
face à une météo compliquée neige
Blizzard ou vent même la Californie
moins habituée est en alerte